[Music]
conrad's dead
who's conrad
[Music]
michelle cotter 17 year old girl
texts her friends for three days telling
them her boyfriend's missing but this
girl knew he wasn't missing
she was in contact with him the whole
time
right up until he killed himself
just texts due respect
those are messed up texts
i think she was telling him to do it
encouraging him
i keep finding things out about him
it's like i didn't even know him
it means so much to see you all here for
conrad it's strange that someone so
close to him and we never met what do
you think dying is like just like
floating on water
they've opened an investigation into
your connection with the death of conrad
roy but i didn't do anything wrong there
are text messages thousands of them
go on say it he was living with you when
it happened think i don't think about it
every goddamn night
we should be like romeo and julia i'd
love to be here juliet but you do know
what happens in the end
is this his first suicide attempt no
this kid has a history of depression
how's this girl responsible this time
there's no law against assisted suicide
in this state she told him to drink
bleach
all he thought about was dying really
just wanted to help him
if we tried this
it would be precedent-setting
when do you believe michelle parker
murdered your son i'm just talking tell
me what to do what motive could she
possibly have today
because carter will not be testifying
this whole thing is alive he was the
love of my life
i want to tell our story
our love story
[Music]
[Music]
you